Ecuador cada vez más desesperado ante la
ola de violencia atentados secuestros
asesinatos han llevado al gobierno a
tomar medidas de fuerza por decisión del
Consejo de Seguridad del estado y los
grupos criminales vinculados al
narcotráfico internacional serán
consideradas terroristas por representar
una amenaza para el estado
mismo como amenaza
que contra los elementos estructurales
del estado y por su consiguiente a su
seguridad integral como está concebido
en la normativa internacional y la
legislación ecuatoriana la medida
permitirá movilizar a militares sin
necesidad de decretos de Estados de
excepción con el fin de enfrentar a los
grupos que mantienen nexos con los
carteles mexicanos de Jalisco Nueva
Generación y Sinaloa el secretario de
seguridad también recomendó al
presidente otras medidas
expedir un decreto ejecu
tivo Estableciendo
coercitivas
urgentes y eficaces que incluyan el
empleo incluso de las armas letales de
las armas letales para combatir esta
grave amenaza que afecta al pueblo
ecuatoriano a nivel interno no se
especificaron qué bandas serán
consideradas terroristas pero el litoral
ecuatoriano cuenta con presencia de
grupos como los choneros los lagartos o
Los chone Killers grupos que se disputan
el tráfico de drogas hacia Estados
Unidos y Europa El Ejecutivo ha culpado
a las bandas de la violencia en las
cárceles del país que dejó más de 400
muertos en 2021 a principios de mes
asaltantes armados atacaron a Pescadores
en la ciudad fronteriza de esmeraldas
matando a nueve personas que hasta ahora
la oleada de violencia es un problema
para el cual un impopular Guillermo
lasso no ha logrado dar solución